yo what is up everybody this procedure
man Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video now there's going
to be a pretty chill video this is the
last video I'm going to be put up before
christmas day I'm not going to do any
videos on Christmas Day because I do
celebrate Christmas and I think y'all
should celebrate like Yvonne silver
christmas but celebrate sometime in the
holidays just be merry and be swagged
full so there's going to be a short
little video and it's going to be about
a little bit of christmas and holiday
cheer that's happening in the precinct
well if you head over to trani's waste
and go to where you usually find your
jira you will find the cool surprise of
Audrey mere now I this is a big dragon
he looks like he's basically just a
reskinned neo jira I think his name is a
mix between Odin yamir and something
else Odin is a Norse God yamir's a frost
giant it needs to kill and Jill I have
no idea what it is so you will get some
nice loot if you kid if you get lucky
when you kill them so basically any he
actually does take a good while to kill
so uh yeah just just shooting down a
bunch with your weapons and make him go
bye-bye and once you kill him enough
times you'll find that he drops the he
has a chance of dropping the Avalanche
and a chance of dropping the old painful
and you saw that I got no prefixes on
either of those so these are both the
vanilla versions of each item you can
see the old painful I saw a shot a
little bit it bit it's a flat off unique
assault rifle it's five it's i believe
it's always fire it might not be though
i'm gonna say it's always fire and it
shoots like these cyber Eagles or shoots
like laser gun a laser gun almost but
it's not super laser e and it just use
the slaughter of lambeth is I'll imagine
like a laser shred of fire and you get
this gun and then the Avalanche shield
if you don't know it's a roid shield so
when your shields are to plead it you
get the shield you get the melee damage
boost it is a cryo hence the name
and melee attackers feel can get turn
can be get the effects of the cryo from
the from just hitting you so if you're
you get attacked by a bunch of things
then they'll go for us and yet this
isn't really sure the effectiveness of
the assault rifle because these are
kragens so they resist the fire
elemental but yeah so hope you guys have
a wonderful holiday um and you get this
little good cheese stuff I'm assuming
there's gonna be a shift code to get the
gun in a little bit of time since that's
what they did with the Jag the Jack Jack
can and jacko cannon um during Halloween
so yeah guys have a good holiday and
I'll see you all later um yeah peace out